Jamar Moore is expecting his first child
with girlfriend Desiree design I'm proud
of what I've accomplished I'm blessed
the Criminal Mind star announced the
happy news on Instagram and opens up on
an upcoming episode of the Jennifer
Hudson show in real life Shemar Moore is
about to be a daddy
[Applause]
Shamar even shared
under reveal party today is the day your
boy got butterflies no this is a special
day this is a legendary day today your
boy Shamar Franklin Moore is about to
find out if he's gonna be a daddy to a
little girl or to a little boy I'm about
to be a father come February 8th 2023.
[Applause]
[Applause]
the couple's expecting a baby girl whom
they plan to name Frankie Frankie little
baby girl so who's the
who's the mama actress and model Desiree
design I am excited I'm anxious I'm just
so excited for this portion of our life
together and it's
good here's what we know she's appeared
in shows like True Blood Hawaii 5-0 and
Days of Our Lives plus she signed with
model agency Willamina and recently did
a campaign for Merle Norman Cosmetics
another title Desiree holds mom of two
to teenage son Caden and five-year-old
daughter Charlie from previous
relationships I would love a boy because
my boy is easy and I could have 10 of
him
but
I kind of want a girl because then we
can have one more because if I have a
boy or one and done and that's not okay
with you but I honestly just want
whatever is healthy happy like he says
10 fingers ten toes while Shamar and
Desiree are giving fans a glimpse inside
their lives they've largely kept their
romance out of the spotlight and it's
unclear when they began dating or how
they met but in this since deleted Tick
Tock recapping 2022 Desiree shared a few
moments with her bow fans can expect to
learn more about the happy couple on the
Jennifer Hudson show when it airs on
January 26th I was worried for a while
that maybe that ship had sailed kind of
thing and and you know God had my back
and things lined up and uh it's going to
be the best part of my my life is pretty
Grand but I know whenever God does Call
My Name once I get this experience I'll
be able to go to heaven whole
[Music]
foreign